[Captions by Y Translator]
In this video,
we're unboxing our very
first King of Random kit.
Everything you need to build
a fully functional laser blowgun
all in one box.
[Music]
Guys, the first-ever
King of Random DIY kit is here,
and we are about to show it
off to you what's inside,
how to build it,
and some fun things
to do with it.
I love this caution tape.
Everything.
Like, I'm super happy
with like just with
how the whole kit looks,
and I didn't design this.
I'm not bragging
that I design something nice.
This is nicer than something
I would have designed.
Custom printing on the box,
got this fun King of Random caution tape.
It's pretty box.
I'm gonna break it.
[Music]
Give me that.
Thank you.
Much prettier.
[Music]
1, 2, 3.
That's really cool.
Look at this.
It comes with stickers?
Comes with stickers?
It comes with a glue gun.
Oh, wow. That's like actually legit.
Okay. This is my favorite.
It's instruction manual
with our target.
Seems simple enough.
There we go.
A little postcard,
from The King of Random.
Little zip ties, pre-cut PVC,
that is useful.
We've got three
different pieces here.
I think one is going
to be joining them together,
one's a mouthpiece,
and one is to hold
the laser sight,
and it does come with a laser.
So we literally just
send everything you
could possibly need in the kit.
There are two,
well sort of three
things not included.
One is electricity
to run the glue gun.
We do not provide that.
You must provide
your own electricity.
But we do include glue sticks.
There are some small screws,
and we do not provide
a screwdriver,
but these are pretty nice.
They have the kind of head
so you can use either
a Phillips screwdriver,
or a flat head screwdriver,
or if you don't have
either of those,
you can just use
a kitchen knife,
like that'll work fine too.
So we don't include one,
but everyone can find something
that will work as a screwdriver
for these screws.
All right, lots
of little paper tabs,
and the paper cone.
A whole roll of electric tape.
Also included,
two sets of stickers you
can use as decoration.
You don't have to use these,
but you can.
Dibs some pink one.
We also do not provide
pair of scissors.
You are going to need those.
So electricity, screwdriver,
pair of scissors.
That's the only things
we do not provide
for this project in the box.
It's pretty complete.
We've got all our stuff.
It's a lot of stuff.
Let's try building it.
First, let's plug in
one of the glue guns.
Get that warming up.
Nate's become a kitty cat.
All right.
Now, one of the first things
we're actually going to do is
if you want to use
these camo stickers,
you want to apply those
before you start
assembling everything.
So, like I said,
I'm claiming the pink one.
Sticker is just
like it's custom-made to be
just the right size fit nicely
around the PVC pipes
that are included.
So all I'm just going to do is
line it up nice and straight,
and then roll it on.
[Music]
All right. So next step is you've
got this mid sized piece here,
cut PVC.
That's going to be your coupler.
It's going to hold
these two pieces together.
These stickers have
like a little King
of Random logo in one spot,
and that's a...
I mean I prefer to have
that down near the mouthpiece.
So don't put
the coupler on there.
Make sure it goes
on the other end.
This also comes
with some electrical tape.
This is largely decorative.
We don't really use this
as a structural element,
but I'm going to use
that to cover this coupler.
So it doesn't just look
like a piece of PVC.
So here's the thing guys,
we provide you with tape,
we provide you
with decorative stickers,
awesome things,
but feel free to customize
this however you want.
That's the whole point.
Now that our pipes
are coupled together,
let's add a mouthpiece.
That's what the shortest
one is going to be.
That's going to go on the end
with the King of Random logo.
At least, that's
how I'm doing it.
Do it yourself.
You want on the other end,
that's fine.
If you don't even want
to use this sticker,
and you want to decorate
with other stuff,
that's fine too.
Multi-purpose weapons.
All right, as this coming along,
now I'm going to attach,
these little foam things,
and they're partially
cut through,
so I'm just gonna break
through the rest away,
fit them over,
and then another layer
of electrical tape.
So these are for holding
your darts in place
so you always have
your ammo close at hand.
So here, we're adding another
layer of electrical tape,
and that's simply just
to hold the foam in place.
All right, next up.
We've got a couple
of different ways
that we can mount our laser
onto our blowgun here.
If you want,
you can take these zip ties,
and zip-tie your laser directly
to the body of the blowgun.
Now that is one way
to mount the laser on,
but it's not the best way.
We included it as an option
so that you can do it
if you prefer.
However, I've got a method
that I like more,
and it's what we've got
the pieces for.
So the other way of mounting
your laser is to actually
use the eight screws
that are included,
drive them into this piece
of PVC that's been pre-cut for you,
and secure your laser inside
for precision pointing.
[Music]
I made a pet.
So now we've got
the screws driven
into our little pieces of PVC,
let's fit the laser
pointer down inside,
and tighten up the screws
just a little bit.
We're still going to do like
calibration of the laser later,
but we can start.
We don't really need
the key chain attachment.
That just pops right off.
Our lasers now mounting
this little housing,
and we're going to glue
this onto the blowgun.
It's kind of up to you
where you want it.
It should be high enough
that it clears the coupling
right in the middle.
So even if you wanted
on the back side,
it's going to work.
I think for me,
I'm just going to put it right
in front of the coupling.
I don't have a reach
that's quite as long as Nate,
so I'm going to go ahead,
and put my laser pointer right
behind the coupling.
So it's a little bit closer
to the mouth guard.
You want to make sure not to get
the glue on your screws
if you ever want to adjust
the site on your laser.
So as I said before,
lots of different ways
that you can customize
your own blowgun.
We're going to go
with spray paint.
[Music]
Beautiful blue laser sight.
Customization is
highly encouraged.
Now, we're going to start
making some darts.
We've got our blowguns.
We've got the lasers
attached to them.
Now, we need a piece of paper,
comes lots of these little
squares of paper.
It's got this set
of 12 clear stickers.
It's really hard
to tell with these are
because they're clear.
But this is
12 small round stickers,
and a small nail.
Be aware that making these darts
with the nails does make
them very dangerous.
You should not ever shoot there
anything that can be damaged,
or is alive,
or can feel pain,
just a bad idea.
Use at your own risk,
and be very careful.
So this is pretty cool.
These little paper cups are just here
to get exactly the right size
and shape of form that you want
for your little paper cones.
What we're going
to do is take one
of our clear circle stickers.
That's going to be our tape.
So we just wrap one of our,
one of these square
pieces of paper.
We just wrap it around the cone,
leave a very small
hole at the top,
and then just use
a sticker to seal it.
Now, if you want
to reinforce this, you can.
You should still have like an
entire roll of electrical tape.
You can wrap that around,
and you're going
to have a little bit
more sturdy of a cone.
It's going to hold up longer.
It's going to be waterproof,
if you do a really good job
of covering it in tape.
But for now,
we are just going to keep
using that one sticker to show
how it works.
Once we've got
the little cone made,
obviously, it's not even
all the way around,
we need to grab a nail,
and go back to our glue gun.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to take our nail,
and you're going to drop
it into your cone,
and that little hole
that you've left at the bottom,
let it fall through.
And you're going to hold
it up a little ways so
the nail hasn't completely
dropped through.
This way,
you can drop a little bit
of hot glue right
around the top of that nail.
And then, pull it the rest
of the way down.
[Music]
We're going to take our dart,
fit into the end of the gun,
and just twist.
And this should leave
a mark on the paper
that will show us
where we need to trim it.
Because obviously, we have
too much paper right now.
[Music]
At this point,
we should have
functional blowguns
with functional blow darts.
And I think going to do is
zero in our sight,
so it's a little more accurate.
[Music]
To get our laser sight
it in just right,
we've got the blowgun in a vice,
and we just want to make sure
that it's nice and level.
So right now,
it's being held very
gently in the vice.
Once I get it level right there,
look how he's going
to tighten it a little bit.
Now, what we're going to do is
we're going to take one of the darts.
We're going to fire it as
hard as we can at the target,
and then we're going
to twist the screws,
moving them around
until the laser lines up right
with where the dart hits.
So we can see our laser dot
does not line up very well,
but that's why
we have adjustable.
We need to adjust the laser
until that dot is right
where the dart hit the target.
So adjusting your laser
and making sure
that you're citing is accurate
isn't really that difficult.
All you've got to do is loosen
or tighten the screws
that are holding it in place,
and you should be able
to get it even.
[Music]
Bullseye.
The kit does come with a target,
and I've used some of the tape
and tape it to the box,
so you do have a target
that's already included.
You can use this.
You don't have to be
using a dartboard.
Let's a...
Let's try shooting this bad boy.
[Music]
I think I just
stabbed another dart,
like perfectly nested.
You shot one dart
through another dart,
Robin Hood style.
That one just shot right
through that one.
If you want a slightly less
dangerous version of projectile,
you can use a bamboo skewer,
instead of the provided nails.
And if you're really
worried about it,
you can even sand down the tip,
so it's not quite so pointy.
[Music]
So obviously,
the bamboo is not nearly...
Less piercing power.
Less lethal.
Barely, barely stuck
into the cardboard.
Wanna go for a moving target.
Do you want me to throw it?
Yes.
This is a terrible idea.
Ready?
Pull.
I hit it.
Did you really?
Oh my God.
He hit it.
It wasn't a good hit,
but I hit it.
Yeah, it's kind
of way too windy,
and dangerous for that.
So we're not going
to do that anymore,
but I did get one hit.
[Music]
I think it went through it.
Oh, no!
I went right through it.
The kit is here,
and it is awesome.
Don't forget that you can download
your own digital target
at TheKingofRandom.com.
It's also fun to experiment with
different types of ammunition.
I'm pretty sure you could get
some marshmallows
to work in this beautifully.
So then you can have like a
laser assisted marshmallow gun.
Guys, to get your own kit now,
click the link
in the description.
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't end here.
This box at the top will take
you to our latest video.
And that box down
to the bottom will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you're not subscribed,
hit that bomb in the middle.
That will get you subscribe
to the channel,
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.